Star Wars fans might best recognize
domhnall gleeson as the sneaky general
Hux who helps lead up the first-order
but the Irish actor has actually
assembled an impressive resume over the
last few years from sci-fi extravaganzas
to gritty period pictures here's what
you might have seen domhnall gleeson
starring in before he ventured out into
a galaxy far far away Harry Potter and
the Deathly Hallows Star Wars wasn't
don't out Gleason's first foray into
franchise land he also enjoyed a brief
stint in the final Harry Potter films as
the eldest Weasley kid bill who's come
back from working overseas to marry
Fleur Delacour and take a nice desk job
before the second Wizarding war erupts
although Gleeson has joked that his red
hair was the real reason it got the gig
his ruby locks had very little to do
with the spell he'd cast over audiences
never let me go although we've been
working for about a decade before never
let me go came out in 2010 the dystopian
drama about a group of teen clones who
have been bred to service organ donors
helped launch Gleeson into the
mainstream his role was relatively brief
in the picture but sharing the screen
with an all-star cast that included
Keira Knightley Andrew Garfield Carey
Mulligan and Ella Pernell certainly
didn't hurt more importantly the film
connected him with screenwriter Alex
Garland whom he would later work with
again on several other projects True
Grit in the Coen brothers acclaimed
Western adaptation Gleeson played moon a
soft-spoken outlaw question by Jeff
Bridges US Marshal the character meets a
rather grisly end after answering some
questions for bridges lawman but while
his role isn't big it's certainly
memorable and Gleeson was happy to
accept such a brief part in the picture
because as he put it he'd rather do one
day on a really cool movie than six
months on something crap Dredd Gleeson
continued his trend of small roles in
good movies when he popped up in the
cult hit Dredd as the clan techie in the
peach trees slum block he's the grungy
computer kid who's running the security
cameras and communications but it's
understandable if you may not have
recognized Gleeson buried under all that
grime Black Mirror one of Leeson's most
heart-wrenching roles came courtesy of
the acclaimed sci-fi anthology series
mirror with the episode be right back
which co-starred Hayley Atwell the story
follows a woman grieving the sudden
death of her boyfriend after he's killed
in a car crash Gleason offers a haunting
performance as the boyfriend and then an
AI reconstruction of the young man's
personality designed to help Atwells
character grieve his passing the two
stars work made the episode one of the
most acclaimed in the anthology series
and Gleason said he loved the ambition
of the segment noting it asks some
really interesting questions in a way
that some of his favorite films asked
really interesting questions about times
trading in the supporting roles for a
leading man gig Gleason headlined the
romantic comedy about time alongside
Rachel McAdams the story focuses on a
man who learns he has the ability to
travel back in time which he uses to woo
the love of his life with the film
marking one of Gleason's first starring
roles at a major production he said he
had to get used to being in pretty much
every scene saying there is something
wonderful about turning up every day and
knowing that not just the character but
the whole movie kind of rests on your
shoulders ex machina one of Gleason's
most buzzy roles came in the daring
sci-fi flick ex machina where he played
a low-level tech employee tasked with
testing a new AI in android at a private
research facility the film reunited the
actor with writer director Alex Garland
and resulted in one of the most
acclaimed movies of the year which only
helped advance police's career even more
the revenant this powerful period drama
included a small but compelling role for
Gleeson who played fur trader Andrew
Henry alongside Leonardo DiCaprio's nigh
unkillable Hugh glass Gleeson was
understandably proud of how the revenant
turned out but he did admit the shoot
was exceedingly brutal the story takes
place in the dead of winter in the
wilderness and he said that when the
actors were actually working and
shooting it wasn't so bad things went
downhill during the downtime though as
he said when you're out there in and out
of the river standing around and not
knowing if you're going to get to your
bit that day those days suck American
made Gleeson also starred opposite a
Lister Tom Cruise in a mere
in May a tale inspired by a real-life
pilot recruited by a CIA agent to fly
secret spy missions above Central
America Gleason described his character
as basically a composite of different
needs for the script adding that he was
glad the filmmaker has made him part of
the story's action the rest Gleeson has
also starred in a bevy of other picks
including Frank unbroken Brooklyn and
Darren Aronofsky's divisive
psychological thriller mother which
Gleason said spoke to his urge to be a
part of something that shakes people to
their core indeed if there is one common
thread tying his eclectic filmography
together
it's that most of his roles do leave a
lasting impression thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel let's check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]